nine-one-one you know the thing you call
right after WebMD tells you you're not
going to be able to get it out on your
own
nine-one-one is a number so important we
do everything to make kids remember it
from classroom posters to toy phones to
folksy PSAs produced by local fire
houses
hi mrs. Clarke welcome to station four
so who knows when to call 9-1-1
you should call 9-1-1 if a person is
badly hurt or in danger right now if
you're not sure whether it's a real
emergency and there are no adults around
it's a good idea to make the call now
that's true but sometimes you should
call even if adults are around for
instance if someone's dying and the only
adult is Matthew McConaughey maybe don't
leave the decision to him
oh you're bleeding out there Hoss all
right tell you what to do let's get some
bongo drums and a bit of horrible love
and tell that open wound to come
together harm bro we got it done we make
roughly 240 million 911 calls each year
and the dispatchers do amazing work
talking people through childbirth CPR
abductions and home break-ins in fact
we're so accustomed to relying on them
we even call when we don't have an
emergency nine month where is your
emergency
I'm sorry but I the fireworks bill on
I'm sorry you cannot call 911 so bad
you're welcome I think I'm having an
overdose and so is my wife
we made brownies and I think we're dead
time is going by really really really
really slow I guess I'm calling because
I have a baby lizard in my house and I
loud in my arm printer the baby crawled
in your printer no a baby lizard Oh a
lizard where your emergency come on
that's a little boy named Richie hey
you're done paddy oh you're done party
okay now okay now I know I know that
sounds adorable but that kid might have
caused such a mess in that bathroom he
had to call 9-1-1 uh yeah this is Richie
you guys have some sort of emergency
cleanup crew you can send out cuz I am
done going potty we have a lot of faith
in 9-1-1 but the system can break down
more than you think and when it does
people can die as a result
chanel Anderson was delivering
newspapers in the dark in suburban
Atlanta when she careened into this pond
she knew right where she was I don't
have that but 9-1-1 dispatchers can't
find her on their map it took first
responders nearly 20 minutes to get to
her she died because a system we expect
to save our lives failed her and 911
losing valuable time simply because
dispatchers have trouble determining
your location is not unusual
the FCC estimates improving location
accuracy could save over 10,000 lives a
year which seems like a worthwhile goal
people making emergency calls are on the
very short list of things we expect to
be found 100% of the time it's that the
clitoris and Nemo these is not a bad
fish it's not a bad fish he's just
curious and he's capable of more than
you think and the obstacles for 9-1-1
centers don't stop there depending on
where you live they may also be
underfunded understaffed and full of
outdated technology which is fine if
you're describing a radio shack but it's
a little scary when you're describing a
place that handles life-and-death
situations so tonight let's focus on how
on earth we got to this point now the
location problems have a lot to do with
the fact that 70 to 80% of all 9-1-1
calls now come from cellphones and
that's become a problem when everyone
used landlines they could simply match
the call to your billing address and
know exactly where you were but now you
could be anywhere and
of course you have AT&T because then you
can only get reception standing on a
chair right by your livingroom window as
long as it's not cloudy and while no one
wants enters do get some location info
from wireless carriers it varies wildly
sometimes they might only get the cell
tower your call was routed through and
that's why around the country your
chance of them quickly getting your
exact whereabouts ranges from as low as
10% to as high as 95% just watch one
reporter put a dispatch center in
Virginia to the test hi this is Jeff
Rossen with NBC News just want to know
if you can tell me where our location is
on your computer that's not here
absolutely not that's about a quarter
mile away and we're standing in the
actual 9-1-1 center that's it right down
there oh that is not good you never want
to be in a situation where you have to
tell someone I'm actually inside you
right now and if you're thinking if
you're thinking well hold on wait a
minute I can find my location on my cell
phone well you're not alone dispatchers
wonder the same thing I can check in on
Facebook and it'll tell you exactly what
building I'm in I can be at the hockey
game and it tells them at First Niagara
Center checking in on Facebook but when
you call 911 we don't get that accurate
location information so the technology
is out there it's just not getting
tossed at this point that's a good point
because even the Domino's app can tell
where you are and they've barely
mastered the technology to make a
palatable pizza so we asked everyone
from the FCC to public safety groups to
industry trade groups about why it seems
lubbers can find you better than
ambulances can and there doesn't seem to
be a simple satisfying answer broadly
what we were told while services like
uber aren't always 100% accurate either
particularly in rural areas plus
emergency workers would like technology
that can tell them what floor of a
building you're on and no one seems to
know how to do that yet and while the
wireless industry does claim to be
working toward incorporating some of
what uber uses into 9-1-1 location
services it seems there is no guarantee
when that will be ready for widespread
use
what we do know is that the FCC has
mandated they improve accuracy so that
by 2021 carriers deliver a usable
location for callers 80% of the time
which sounds impressive until you put it
like this six years from now 9/11 could
still be unable to find one out of every
five emergency callers that's not good
enough the sentence in six years I might
not be able to find one out of five of
you is only acceptable if you're
speaking to the members of one direction
and I'm sorry Niall but one of you has
to be the JC chasse and and look fixing
the location problem won't fix
everything
911 is so fragmented there are currently
five thousand eight hundred and ninety
nine dispatch centers because each
county or municipality in an area might
have its own one plus there is no
guarantee that any two dispatch centers
use the same technology or have a system
to work together and none of this is
helped by the fact that in six states
there is no specific statewide entity in
charge of coordinating 9-1-1 services
and while Georgia law does require an
actual committee to help develop plans
for 9-1-1 it's not exactly a robust body
this is it Georgia's permanent 911
committee you'll notice all 15 seats are
empty there's no one at the mic and
there's nothing on the agenda this
committee hasn't met for years because
there isn't a single member
currently appointed how the is that
possible we even asked and a
spokesperson claimed that that committee
does actually have members but couldn't
confirm it's active and didn't answer
when we asked for those members names
and come on you can at least make up a
name like I don't know John Miller right
off the top of your head it's clearly
not
and there is a lot that that committee
could be doing for instance for over a
decade the federal government has been
talking about something called next
generation 9 1 1 basically upgrading
dispatch centers to an ip-based network
and enabling them to do things like
accept videos and text messages and that
could be life-saving
in situations where you can't make a
phone call like domestic violence or a
home invasion or having a heart attack
in a library I mean sure get some help
but have some respects for the other
patrons but as of right now no state has
fully implemented next-gen 9-1-1 which
makes no sense this would make
everything so much easier for the
dispatchers whose jobs are frankly hard
enough already
some days depending upon the outcome
it's good other days not sometimes you
really don't know the outcome and you go
home at night and you wonder is it
something I could have done that would
have prevented maybe this person from
dying or this person from getting hurt
and then there are other times when you
might save a life that you go home and
you you know you pat yourself on the
back you're driving home and you you cut
the music up and you're saying to
yourself why I did something really good
ok I mean that is a wider extreme the
most of experience in our daily jobs for
me the difference between a good day and
a bad day is whether there's hazelnut
creamer in the break room or whether
Janice from accounting drank it all
again god damn it Janice that's not even
milk that's disgusting and that level of
stress combined with funding shortages
has caused dispatch centers to be
understaffed in fact right now go to
Google put in understaffed 9-1-1
dispatch and your town and see what
comes up because in many places it will
be headlines like these it seems 9-1-1
staffing problems one of those things a
ridiculous number of cities have like a
chinatown or a statue of someone racist
and
and if your local dispatch center is
understaffed then when you call the
first voice you hear maybe this
separates Memphis 9-1-1 emergency all
operators are busy so please remain on
the line
you've reached the cincinnati 9-1-1
center your call will be answered as
soon as possible
you have reached New Hanover County 911
experiencing high volumes of emergency
calls you have reached 9-1-1 emergency
dispatch do not hang up it's in danger
lay down the phone and go to safety oh
go to safety why didn't I think of that
Here I am in danger when really I could
simply be going to safety I shouldn't
have wasted your time by calling in the
first place and some of that call volume
is on us the ubiquity of cell phones
means if 50 people see a fire 9-1-1
might get 50 calls and that's on top of
an even bigger strain on the system
approximately 84 million 911 ation wide
are but dials one person even but dial
nine-one-one 136 times when you receive
a call and it's from as we call the the
but dial there's really not a whole lot
you can do when I tell that but dial
them they always sound kind of
aggravated I mean it's kind of a waste
of their time you know okay make sure
you don't call again okay
honestly I'm willing to bet that guy
hears the same response from just about
anyone he dials by accident or on
purpose so look we have an antiquated
disjointed system populated by workers
who are understandably sick of listening
to people's butts and what makes this
even more frustrating is that almost
everyone's phone bill has a line like
this on it which you might assume goes
directly to fund 9-1-1 centers but but
the FCC's fee reports show that since
2008 at least 20 states have diverted
those dollars elsewhere which is
probably why depending on where you live
9-1-1 may be a joke in your town to
quotes duran duran I mean I know it's a
Public Enemy song but did you know that
Juran georan covered it
you're welcome because you haven't heard
that disaffected anthem properly until
you've had it performed by a white man
named Simon from Hartford sheer the
point is we are routinely raiding 911 to
pay for other things New York State
which has seen multiple breakdowns in
its 9-1-1 systems took in over a hundred
and eighty five million dollars in fees
in 2014 but then diverted 77 million
into the state's general fund where it
could be spent on pretty much anything
and yet when the governor was asked
about this he blew it off is that
something in the budget process that
you'll take a look at is it right for us
to divert this money it is not an issue
that has come up and I haven't heard any
local legislature raise it but if it
comes up and look into it
okay.i it just king came up the
legislators have raised the issue
repeatedly since you've been in office
and see not diverting money away from
911 is one of those things you shouldn't
have to be told not to do like softening
gas out of a fire truck to put in your
dirt bike oh no one's told me this is
wrong so if you'll excuse me I'm gonna
spin some dough locks in that Arby's
parking lot but this blasé attitude is
indicative of the fact that until we're
explicitly confronted with the
challenges facing 9-1-1 it seems we're
not going to do anything about them and
maybe the problem is that we are taught
from a young age to take 9-1-1 for
granted so perhaps it's time for that to
change
so you should call 911 is badly hurt or
in danger any questions yeah so if I
called I what what don't come and help
me
well I'm sure gonna try sweetie but I
gotta be honest if you're calling from a
cell phone and you don't know your
address a lot of the time we're gonna
struggle to find out exactly where you
are that's scary
well don't you worry by the Year 2021 we
will find you every time four out of
five times wait how can you not know how
to find me I can order pizza from my
phone right now and they know exactly
where I am it's not the same thing I
just did it there's a pizza on sway you
know what I'm gonna get a dispatcher to
come explain this to you hey kids
firefighter bill said you had some
questions about why we're not able to
find you all the time yeah why is that
well we just don't have the technology
to pizzas here get out on the
bright side some places have pretty good
statewide systems like Maine hey my
grandma lives in Maine well then she
should be fine my panda lives at Georgia
who she is totally why don't you
guys just try harder excuse me
oh you think I don't try hard I
just worked a 12-hour shift
I hope deliver three babies I saved a
family from a fire I pulled a lizard out
of a printer and I listened to 15
different but
oh yeah well we'll see how hard you're
laughing when I'm listening to someone's
ass and you're all burning to death in
your beds it's so hard to flame the lick
in my body
okay who wants to pet a Dalmatian
nine-one-one we'll be there when you
need us
some restrictions apply availability may
be limited offer not guaranteed in all
states actual response time may vary
contact a medical professional if you
experience awake time longer than four
hours
you